when you made the transition you said
that you're 10 you that's when you
started being yourself more on stage
that's when i changed my style i was
like myself i just was saying
yeah i just changed what i was going to
be talking about i didn't want to talk
about nothing that
somebody generally was going to i was
going to do a lot more research a lot
more studying and go
in depth on [ __ ] and find the most
gruesome [ __ ] to make funny
and saying even even the stuff that
inside me hey you ain't you ain't you
haven't been telling these stories
people don't realize people don't
realize this at all
i hadn't told a prison story until i did
this is not happening
whoa and you've had multiple albums
before that
that's some that's wow i hadn't i
hadn't told not one prison story what
was that consciously or you just said
that was very conscious i didn't want
people to think i was some one trick
oh ollie do it every night right i'm not
the prison comic
so it took me 16 years
i was going to stand up for 16 years
before i ever remember
i did no 8 i did death jam out of the
season finale on def jam
i was on comic view 2001 to 2004
i was on off the chain i was on bill
billers who got jokes
i was on a lot of stuff before i did
this is not happening
and you had the vision to know i don't
want to be that so i'm saving
that i just not even thought i was gonna
ever even do it was just
it's like i told stories to my friends
so
they were like man one of these days man
you gotta say that on
stage and i never he's like bill told me
to say a bunch of stuff
and then the the thing comes when
a person who is your mentor says hey man
you wanna be you want me to be real with
you
the funny how funny you gonna be
is determined on how honest you gonna be
i mean that's when that's when you're
going to be different when you decide
that you have whatever honesty whatever
truth you want to say
that's when you're going to start being
[ __ ] hysterical
and that was dl higgly
just like when when cheryl underwood
told me
which sometimes she [ __ ] forget that
she told me this because she
acted like she had forgetting she even
know me or some [ __ ]
but on the time join the cruise i never
forget it and and
this is the crazy thing [ __ ] like she
don't [ __ ] know me but i say
i say this story and very in
[ __ ] the detail is that i can
say it
because it is going to be nothing but
straight detail
she was coming out of the spa on the
cruise she had on this [ __ ] long
floyd thing that was like blue and green
with a little splash of red but it was
white based this [ __ ] flip big flip
hat on
and we talking and she said i had dress
at the time
she said ali i'll tell you something
you wanna be successful uncommon you
gotta remember these two things
every man gotta wanna be
you and every [ __ ] gotta wanna [ __ ]
you that's serious
and and i and i thought about what she
said
and it's the truth
to be successful and stand up
every man gotta want to be you
it won't be funny every woman
god wanna [ __ ] you 85 percent of any
comedy club
made up of women if you are not
attractive
no and i'm talking about one thing is
you ask any woman
this is a psychology issue when you go
deeper into it when you ask any woman
name your top three things you want your
man to be
i guarantee you [ __ ] funny come
up
make me laugh come up i guarantee cause
funny and sexy
that transcends you pass what's your
physical [ __ ] look like
shame that she was right and so i cut my
hair
i um i tailored up i was already
dressing with
taylor's suits and [ __ ] but i tailored
up more
i i switched my style up a lot
and i
combined with d.l and cheryl said
together
there's other there's other people out
there as well but
like dick gregory and dez white and rob
stapleton there's a lot of other people
who
who gave me solid ass advice
so when i get ready to write a book
which would be soon here
um awesome it'll be a book of
quotes i think
the story i'ma lay the story out of how
i got the quote
like it's gonna be the quote then it's
gonna be the story
behind the quote and then i want to get
the person who who told me the quote to
sign
in the book
[Music]